c'est l'heure de notre second débat
secondaire des bas de société pour
prendre vous le savez volontairement du
recul sur l'actualité du jour je vous
propose un chiffre aujourd'hui 97
détenus incarcérés pour des faits de
terrorisme islamistes sont sortis de
prison l'an dernier après avoir purgé
leur peine une centaine d'autres
libération est prévue cette année la
réinsertion de ces djihadistes est-elle
possible la déradicalisation menée dans
les prisons françaises étaient efficace
avant d'en débattre notre reportage sur
ce thème il est signé Norbert
Evangéliste
un homme meurtri Mourad Benchellali veut
croire sa réinsertion réussie pourtant
20 ans après sa condamnation l'étiquette
de djihadiste lui colle encore à la peau
c'est une on va dire que c'est une
réinsertion qui
qui est fragile dans la mesure où on me
renvoie beaucoup beaucoup à mon passé un
voyage en Afghanistan l'influence d'un
frère radicalisé et le début d'un enfer
surtout quand je suis dans ce camp
d'entraînement et qui a Oussama Ben
Laden qui vient il prenait des attentats
suicide au moins là je comprends la
gravité des choses et j'entrai pour la
première fois de ma vie dans un univers
que je connaissais pas qui est celui du
terrorisme donc évidemment que j'ai
qu'une seule envie c'est de fuir
seulement bon ben quand je sors de ce
camp ce sont les attaques du 11
septembre et donc le piège se referme
puisque les Américains entre en guerre
entrer en guerre avec l'Afghanistan
après deux ans dans le camp de
Guantanamo presque autant dans les
joules françaises Mourad bénéficie d'un
non-lieu
alors commence le long chemin de la
réinsertion un travail qu'il mène seul
besoin de se blanchir partager son
expérience empêcher les plus vulnérables
de basculer dans la radicalisation mais
là encore il affronte la défiance
j'étais dans une sortie sèche
ce qui a été compliqué ça a été
d'obtenir la confiance des institutions
quand j'ai décidé quand je voulais mener
mon travail de prévention c'est-à-dire
que j'étais confronté à des rectorats
qui avaient peur de moi à des à des
agents dans des administrations avec
pour lesquelles pourtant je collaboré
qui était très méfiante et qui en creux
pensaient qu'elles avaient fait entrer
le loup dans la bergerie
à sa sortie de prison Benchellali avait
été lâché dans la nature depuis la
recrudescence des candidats au djihad a
poussé l'administration judiciaire à
prendre en charge les condamnés Soumagne
justice au sein d'une structure
nationale spécialement adaptée pour ça
c'est accompagnement peut aller de une à
trois heures pour les personnes les plus
réinsérer qui ont déjà pris de la
distance avec cette radicalisation
violente et pour les profils les plus
complexes la prise en charge peut aller
jusqu'à 20h par semaine et c'est à
travers une équipe pluridisciplinaire
que que nous avons composé de
travailleurs sociaux de conseiller en
insertion professionnelle de
psychologues et de médiateurs
interculturels et du fer religieux de
pouvoir accompagner tous les aspects du
parcours de vie de la de la personne et
puis surtout de susciter le doute par
rapport à tous les principes qu'ils ont
pu intégrer et qui les amènent à cette
radicalisation violente parmi les 270
personnes accueilli au Groupe SOS aucune
n'a récidivé ni montrer l'intention de
le faire le premier vrai pas franchi
vers la réinsertion Mourad quant à lui
poursuit sa croisade auprès des jeunes
dans cette bande dessinée il revient sur
son aventure j'aurais aimé la réécrire
cette histoire
la réécrire et tout faire différemment
une histoire qui a bouleversé sa vie à
jamais
près de 1500 Français seraient partis en
Irak et en Syrie pour rejoindre daesh
l'État islamique entre 2012 et 2019
selon le ministère de la Justice à la
fin du mois de septembre de l'an dernier
2022 129 de cjihadistes dont 51 femmes
étaient incarcéré en France que faire de
ces hommes et de ses femmes peut-on les
réinsérer voilà la question principale
de ce débat je vous présente mes invités
marketer bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directeur de la recherche à l'IFRI
auteur de la guerre de 20 ans djihadisme
et contre terrorisme au 21ème siècle
publié aux éditions Robert Laffont et
chargé de l'évaluation du principal
programme de déradicalisation française
intitulée djihadiste un jour djihadiste
toujours Roger caoutchi bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous sénateur LRD onsen et
vice-président du Sénat Martin Pradel
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
avocat au barreau de Paris et vous avez
notamment défendu des grands-parents
d'enfants de djihadistes Mathieu
croissanto éditoris politique rebonsoir
Mathieu merci d'être resté à nos côtés
peut-être une question de pour commencer
Marc équerre est-ce que ce terme de
déradicalisation vous l’employez dans
les chercheurs ne l'emploi plus trop les
la haute fonction publique non plus on
continue à l'employer au quotidien parce
que c'est compréhensible mais c'est vrai
qu'on ne l'emploi plus parce que ça
supposerait qu'on est capable d'inverser
un logiciel dans un dans un cerveau ce
qui n'est pas le cas un jour un gardien
de prison m'a dit on ne peut pas
perquisitionner un cerveau et c'est tout
à fait vrai donc les le terme qui
aujourd'hui
justement c'est très difficile de
mesurer le degré précis de
radicalisation même s'il y a des
évaluations qui sont faites donc le
terme qui est aujourd'hui privilégié
c'est celui de désengagement ce qui
permet de voir qu'une personne par ses
actes sort effectivement de la voix de
la violence et essaye de se réinsérer on
parle aussi de réinsertion on parle de
réhabilitation de réaffiliation sociale
le programme qui a été évoqué dans votre
reportage s'appelle le programme Perez
et le r C'est la réaffiliation et le S
social donc on voit qu'il y a des
différentes terminologies qui sont
privilégiés par rapport à ce terme qu'on
continue d'employer usuellement parce
que ça parle à tous de d'éradicalisation
Roger caoutchi c'est politique de de
réinsertion de d'éradicalisation dans
nos prisons est-ce que vous voulez jugez
efficace comment vous les évaluez je
sais pas moi de juger je ne suis pas un
expert en revanche clairement d'ailleurs
j'ai lu la synthèse faite par les frites
à deux ans
les programmes antérieurs ont été des
échecs il y a eu une série de programmes
qui ont été mises en place en
Seine-Saint-Denis dans d'autres
départements et qu'on a fini d'ailleurs
par arrêter tellement même les autorités
publiques ont fini par dire bon ça ne
marche pas ça n'a pas de sens on a mis
en place alors effectivement vous le
dites nouveau programme depuis
maintenant quoi trois ans quatre ans
on verra le recul de peut-être pas
suffisant encore pour dire ça marche
bien ça marche pas
la réalité c'est pour ça que je moi non
plus je n'utilise pas trop le terme de
d'éradicalisation c'est que dans le fond
on a bien du mal à savoir quels sont les
résultats
pour des gens j'allais dire
radicalisés dans le passé mais n'étant
jamais passé à l'acte ou n'ayant jamais
engagé la violence l'agression il y a un
travail d'ailleurs j'ai vu que on
faisait venir de plus en plus de
théologiens musulmans d'imam pour
trouver un petit peu les voies de
passage dans dans les procédures qui
sont certainement plus intéressantes que
simplement des juristes mais eux-mêmes
disent
on n'en sait rien peut-être que la
personne s'en sortira bien peut-être pas
il faut attendre un peu il faut voir si
une fois sorti notamment de l'univers
carcéral
il ne reviennent pas dans une ambiance
un bain plus radicalisé auquel cas quel
sera le résultat réel du désengagement
je n'en sais rien et ça pose
effectivement la question de la du suivi
à la sortie de prison de de ceux qui
sont sortis de prison une centaine l'an
dernier encore une centaine prévue cette
année Martin Pradel
est-ce que vous employez ce terme je
reste sur la sémantique est-ce que vous
êtes est-ce que la réinsertion vous
semble possible par exemple pour ceux
qui sont on parle de 1500 français qui
sont allés en Irak ou en Syrie là quand
on est dans ce degré d'engagement pour
répondre à ce que vient de dire monsieur
carucci à l'instant je pense que il faut
quand même avoir à l'esprit que ces
programmes de désengagement d'éradiquer
c'est vrai que les professionnels
aujourd'hui n'utilisent plus trop le
terme de de de d'éradiquer ce sont des
programmes qui s'adressent à des
personnes qui sont comme on dit
couramment judiciarisés c'est-à-dire que
c'est des personnes qui aux yeux de la
justice sont suspectés d'avoir commis
une infraction et pas n'importe laquelle
puisque c'est l'association de
malfaiteurs terroristes dont on parle
c'est donc pas des personnes qui ne sont
pas passées à l'acte elles sont passées
à l'acte d'une d'une entente qui a pour
finalité de faire régner l'intimidation
ou la terreur ça c'est c'est ce que la
loi dit et non moi je n'utilise pas à
titre personnel le terme de
d'éradiqualisation qui me semble
effectivement dépourvu de de sens très
concrets je crois que perquisitionner un
cerveau je vais retenir cette phrase
elle est intéressante mais bon après
est-ce que la réinsertion est possible
c'est un peu le débat général qu'on est
en train de se poser et la réponse est
oui
vous en êtes convaincu moi j'en suis
absolument convaincu non seulement j'en
suis convaincu mais c'est à dire que le
jeu je constate des des cadres de
réinsertion c'est à dire que et des cas
enfin c'est à dire ils sont nombreux en
vérité ces personnes qui au terme d'un
parcours dans lequel on leur a tendu la
main où on a cherché à leur faire
comprendre avec sincérité et
l'institution judiciaire elle est là
pour juger mais ceux qui viennent pour
parler avec ces personnes ne viennent
pas pour pour les juger nécessairement
et bien si on va parler à ces personnes
véritablement alors qu'elles sont
souvent dans une difficulté réelle elle
comprennent tout ce qu'elles ont perdu
et tout ce qu'elles ont aussi à gagner à
réfléchir sur elle-même et de fait ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne et c'est vrai
que on ne saura jamais ce qui se passe
dans le cœur d'un homme ou d'une femme
ce qui se passe dans sa tête et comment
il pense véritablement mais il y a des
gages quand même qui sont donnés avec le
temps et c'est vrai que il y a des
programmes qui se sont succédés entre
2015 et 2018 et puis depuis 2018 on se
donne un peu plus le temps et les
professionnels s'en félicitent pour
pouvoir dire avec un peu de recul on
arrive à des résultats qui sont quand
même tangibles mais qu'est-ce qui vous
faisait dit ou qu'est-ce qui vous fait
dire j'ai caoutchi que ça ne les
précédents ne fonctionnait pas
les programmes entre 2000 parce que on a
commencé même dans certains cas des 2011
2012 et jusqu'en 2018
de fait bah qu'est-ce que vous voulez
les gens une fois sorti de prison
récidivets certains sont une fois sortis
de prison et théoriquement traitées
partie en Syrie dans la foulée donc on
peut pas dire que ce soit un franc
succès et à partir de là ces programmes
ont été arrêtés en fait et on a cherché
de nouvelles méthodes alors j'ai le
regret de ne pas partager l'optimisme de
des autres personnes sur ce plateau
c'est vrai que on parvient à à de bons
résultats avec un certain nombre de gens
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'on parvient à
réinsérer à permettre dans la société
complètement
100% des gens que l'on traite évidemment
non il y a forcément une part de gens
qui même si vous leur mettez puisque je
voyais votre reportage 20h par semaine
c'est même pas le sujet c'est il y a des
gens fermés à tout retour vers une
société normale une vie normale et puis
il y a des gens qui se sont laissés
entraîner et qui peuvent revenir sur de
un phénomène social pas pas 100% on
reviendra sur 100% Mathieu voulait
intervenir des hommes ou des femmes en
l'occurrence et qu'est-ce qui dépend du
contexte je vous donne un exemple est-ce
que les nazis ont arrêté d'être nazis
après avoir été emprisonnés est-ce que
les Khmers Rouges ont été arrêté d'être
mis rouge après avoir été emprisonné non
mais le régime nazi était tombé il était
mort non mais le régime mère était mort
et même s'il y avait quelques
nostalgiques du troisième âge qui se
retrouvaient il y avait pas de menaces
en ce sens qui n'était il ne pouvait pas
rétablir
pour revenir au pouvoir là le contexte
de la guerre contre le terrorisme on y
est encore en plein dedans donc est-ce
que ça comment on arrive à mesurer le
cheminement d'un homme et entre
guillemets
les opportunités qu'il peut avoir de de
retomber
la radicalisation à différents niveaux
il y a effectivement des niveaux
individuels micro avec des problèmes qui
peuvent être aussi de nature
psychologique ou sociale pour certains
individus il y a les niveaux macro la
grande géopolitique évidemment ce qui se
passe sans zone sirop irakienne a eu un
impact très fort sur notamment les
attentats qu'on a eu en France et puis
il y a le niveau intermédiaire le niveau
méso ce qui se passe en France qui se
passe dans le quartier la présence de
prêcheurs ou pas donc c'est
effectivement un phénomène complexe avec
des facteurs différents qui jouent sur
la radicalisation et ensuite le passage
à l'acte d'individus j'aimerais revenir
sur ce qu'on a dit avant quand même
vous poser la question sur les 100%,
est-ce que de toute façon les 100% sont
j'ai vu la logique un peu évoluer parce
que vous avez demandé est-ce que c'est
possible oui c'est possible il y a des
success stories on a des exemples très
clairs de personnes qui ont évolué qui
sont et qui depuis des années montre que
elles sont sur un cheminement positif et
certains sont même rentrés dans le
contrediscours dans la pratique de
contre-rédicalisation et votre reportage
montrait un exemple
il y a d'autres exemples de ce type là
100% évidemment que ce n'est pas
possible et donc faut je pense inverser
la logique c'est à dire se demander
parmi la masse qui peut récidiver et
déjà là on se rend compte que on a un
problème de sécurité parce que on
n'exclut pas la problématique de la
récidive mais que dans la grande
majorité des cas est quand même il va y
avoir peut-être pas une réinsertion mais
au moins une absence de récidive est-ce
que le programme dont on parle perdons
il est formaté pour alerter sur une
éventuelle récidive comment ça marche
alors pour moi c'est le point clé à leur
père c'est uniquement en post carcéral
il y a des dispositifs qui sont mis en
place en prison mais perdent ça se passe
donc en dehors avec trois piliers qui
ont été évoqués là encore dans votre
reportage un pilier social c'est-à-dire
avec des travailleurs sociaux qui
essayent de prendre en charge ces
individus pour minimiser les facteurs de
risque en les aidant à retrouver un
travail à changer d'environnement amical
à renouer avec tous les aspects de la
vie vous avez ensuite un pôle
psychologique parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'individus c'est difficile à
quantifier probablement autour d'un
quart qui ont des troubles
psychologiques et une toute petite
minorité qui souffre vraiment de
troubles psychiatriques et puis il y a
un pôle idéologique avec notamment les
imams que vous évoquiez les aumôniers
les spécialistes de Har religion qui
essayent de travailler vraiment sur les
aspects idéologies pour voir quel texte
les individus lisent quels sont leurs
interprétations et essayer de les faire
bouger sur ces aspects là ce travail en
équipe va permettre d'affiner
l'évaluation de ces individus de mesurer
leur progression et effectivement ce
programme
est mis en place dans un environnement
qui existe avec le ministère de la
Justice qui est présent le ministère de
l'Intérieur et pour moi toute la clé de
ce dispositif c'est de faire en sorte
que les relations entre ces différents
pôles soient bien ruinés pour que en cas
de problème l'alerte puisse être donnée
et il y a eu des situations
effectivement compliquées on n'est pas
passé loin de la récidive dans quelques
cas et dans ces cas-là en général
l'alerte a été donné c'est-à-dire que
les travailleurs se rendaient bien
compte qu'il n'arrivaient pas à faire
progresser des individus dans un sens
positif ou que le lien interrompu ou que
le lien était rompu et ils ont quand
même pu jouer un rôle d'alerte ce qui à
mon sens du coup n'est pas un échec du
programme en tant que tel c'est vrai que
les individus n'ont en question n'ont
pas été d'éradicalisés mais ils n'ont
pas récidivé et ils ont pu être
appréhendés en temps et en heure je vais
redonner des chiffres qu'on a déjà vu
puisque vous parlez de ce programme qui
est juste effectivement après
l'incarcération donc détenus incarcérés
pour des fêtes terrorisme islamistes 70
libérés en 2020 84 en 2021 97 l'an
dernier il y en a encore une centaine de
prévu cette année Martin Pradet vous
êtes avocat je le rappelle la question
c'est comment continuer de les
surveiller si on se dit et on peut être
lucide qui a quand même un danger
potentiel pour certains d'entre eux
j'essaie de pas faire d'amalgame tout en
respectant les règles de notre État de
droit ils ont purgé leur peine oui alors
je pense que là-dessus il faut il faut
surtout sortir je pense d'un mythe qui
serait que la justice
pose un regard sur une situation et à
partir du moment où la personne a purgé
sa peine on ne s'en intéresse plus on a
plus le droit de rien faire c'est
absolument pas du tout le cas c'est à
dire que pèse c'est vrai que c'est en
post-antanciel mais ça commence avant
souvent qu'une peine ne soit prononcée
les programmes sont mis en anticipe la
sortie de prison c'est à dire que on se
pose la question et pour les personnes
qui paraissent présenter des conditions
favorables on les met en contact avec ce
programme pour vérifier que les
impressions sont sont confirmés ça c'est
une chose importante mais pour sortir un
peu du mythe je crois que c'est
important de le dire vous avez tout un
dispositif législatif qui permet aux
préfectures de prendre le relais des
contrôles judiciaires pour après la
libération d'une personne alors c'est
critiqué d'ailleurs par par un certain
nombre de personnes mais c'est l'état du
droit aujourd'hui placer une personne
sous une mesure individuelle de
surveillance qui parfois peut être
extrêmement
contraignante qui est à l'initiative du
préfet sous le contrôle du juge
administratif les c'est-à-dire que
n'allons pas laisser croire que les
autorités sont sans moyens vis-à-vis
d'une personne qui sort de prison
pour les les plus ceux qui préoccupent
le plus l'autorité postérieurement donc
à cette peine cette personne ne peut
plus être incarcérée mais vous pouvez
interdire à cette personne de sortir de
chez elle vous pouvez lui demander dans
certains cas de pointer jusqu'à 4 fois
par jour au commissariat du quartier et
disons-le cette personne est sous une
surveillance extrêmement étroite
peut-être même plus étroite que dans
certains milieux de de prison ou les
personnes ont une bien sûr elles sont
sous surveillance mais elles ont une
forme de latitude au sein de la prison
il y a ici une une idée reçue dans notre
société qu'à partir du moment où la
personne a purgé sa peine elle est donc
en liberté et comme son nom l'indique ça
veut dire qu'il n'y a plus aucun
contrôle c'est absolument pas le cas les
personnes qui inquiètent les autorités
et en particulier ministère d'intérieur
ou les préfectures sont sous une mesure
de surveillance qui est extrêmement
étroite et extrêmement efficace quand
même
un an maxi prolongé Nantes maximum bon
alors Roger caoutchi bah j'allais ça
pose la question quoi est-ce que le
dispositif législatif est suffisant et
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de surveiller
d'abord juste pour répondre à Monsieur
croissanto la comparaison avec le régime
nazi ou les Rouges est un peu compliqué
parce que par définition une fois ces
régimes étatique militaires tombés
il y a pas eu de terrorisme nazis poste
régime
aujourd'hui daesh enfin l'état islamique
a entre guillemets disparu mais il
continuait à y avoir des attentats de
daesh d'ailleurs en Syrie en Irak en
Afghanistan et malheureusement aussi en
Occident donc on n'est pas
malheureusement dans la même situation
parce que là c'est vraiment une
idéologie qui continue même s'il y a
plus de détails islamique le deuxième
élément moi je suis d'accord ici
d'ailleurs on a voté un certain nombre
de textes renforçant le contrôle
mais
arrive un moment où on est entre la
sécurité
et le droit et le droit dit parfois
n'allez pas trop longtemps trop loin et
le résultat des courses c'est que ça
vient d'être dit le contrôle post
carcéral d'abord on a un petit sujet
c'est que avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour nos services qui font un travail
remarquable et qui très souvent déjoué
d'ailleurs des attentats
beaucoup plus nombreux que ce que l'on
dit mais
ils sont pas assez nombreux donc le
suivi oui il est bien fait pour les plus
les plus les plus remarqués si je puis
dire il est peut-être un peu moins suivi
pour d'autres et deuxième élément au
bout d'un an il se passe quoi
parce qu'au bout d'un an alors là pour
de bon
ils sont dans la nature c'est à dire que
1 les autorités judiciaires ou
préfectorales non plus le droit
d'exercer de contrôle et donc
c'est-à-dire que il n'y a plus de
contraintes n'allons pas penser on peut
pas laisser croire que nos services se
désintéresseraient
mais il n'y a plus de mesures de
contrainte qui puisse leur être
infligées c'est quand même deux choses
le service fort heureusement on le
parfaitement toute la possibilité de
continuer à surveiller ces individus et
à exercer des mesures en ont-ils les
moyens mais ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
un problème que que dans nos assemblées
parlementaires doivent se saisir
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
vous sortez de l'année donc où cette
surveillance ne peut plus imposer de
contraintes parce que la contrainte
pardon la facilité de dire si comme vous
le disiez un tel doit passer deux fois
trois fois au commissariat dans la
journée il passe où il passe pas il
passe pas on sait qu'il y a un problème
tandis que lorsque au bout de l'année on
peut le surveiller mais on peut plus
rien lui imposer comme contrainte donc
ou bien vous avez beaucoup de personnel
et vous pouvez mettre sur des gens qui
ne sont plus sous contrainte une
capacité de surveillance ou vous n'avez
pas suffisamment de personnel et vous
recentrer sur le personnel sur les gens
les plus dangereux et pas sur les autres
et on sera un tout petit peu parce qu'il
y a quand même des possibilités qui sont
verticompris de contraintes alors elles
sont moindres que ce qu'on appelle les
micaces c'est ces mesures dont on
parlait mais il y a déjà des
inscriptions dans des fichiers le
figette avec notamment un certain nombre
d'obligations en termes de déclaration
de son domicile ou de changement de
domicile ou de voyage et puis par
ailleurs le programme per dont on
parlait avant il y a aussi une évolution
notable qui a été votée à l'été 2021 qui
fait qu'on peut imposer à une personne
de suivre ce programme et pour le coup
c'est pour non plus qu'un an ça peut
aller je crois jusqu'à 5 ans donc il y a
quand même des choses qui existent et
puis encore une fois 2021 ça veut dire
qu'il fallait que les gens acceptent
d'être dans le programme PS après on a
pu leur imposer non c'est pas ça ah bah
si non n'était pas d'accord vous pouviez
pas leur dire d'autorité si vous faites
les lois de juin 2016 qui le permettait
mais ce qui a changé c'est qu'il fallait
que cette peine là soit prononcée au
moment du jugement alors que là en 2021
en fait à la fin de la peine il y a une
nouvelle audience et on peut leur
imposer cette obligation en plus de la
peine initiale qui avait été prononcé je
vais mettre les pieds dans le plat vous
me dites je comprends tout à fait 100%
est totalement inatteignable donc il
faut qu'on se prépare peut-être
intellectuellement psychologiquement à
ce que il y ait une récidive un attentat
commis par
qui est passé par ce par ce programme il
faudra pas pour autant jeter le
programme c'est ce que c'est ce que vous
le dites mais je moi je vois bien ce qui
va se passer l'opinion le fait de devoir
ou de d'avoir la tentation de légiférer
sous l'émotion qu'est-ce que vous
comment vous vous préparez de la
récidive terroriste en France ça il faut
le faire bien sûr shérif kwashi est un
récit divise elle aussi à Bala qui a tué
le couple de policier à Magnanville
était un récitiviste tous les deux
avaient été condamnés pour l'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes dans le cas
de shérif kwashi c'était quasiment enfin
les faits remonter à 10 ans auparavant
la tuerie de Charlie Hebdo donc on voit
que effectivement la durée peut être
passée par des programmes il n'était pas
passé par ce type de programme après on
peut pas refaire l'histoire c'est-à-dire
que ils auraient peut-être commis ces
actes en étant passé par des programmes
de ce type nul nul ne peut le dire mon
point est le suivant c'est que il peut y
avoir de la récidive le rôle des
institutions c'est de réduire au maximum
le risque de récidive mais c'est devenu
une tarte à la crème de dire ça mais le
risque zéro n'existe pas et si jamais un
jour il y a un cadre ici
il faudra pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain c'est à dire que ce programme et
d'autres programmes du même type en
françois l'étranger ont montré qu'ils
avaient une certaine utilité pour des
dizaines voire des centaines d'individus
donc je comprends bien la manière dont
fonctionne nos sociétés où on a tendance
à réagir sous le coup de l'émotion et
parfois légiférer sous le coup de
l'émotion mais je crois que quand il y a
ce genre de tragédie au contraire il
faut faire preuve de sang froid et
encore une fois regarder ce qui
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas
s'il y a un attentat c'est qu'il y a eu
dysfonctionnement donc il faut essayer
de corriger les dysfonctionnements mais
il s'agit pas de faire table rase je
voudrais qu'on parle maintenant de de la
question du rapatriement des des femmes
et de leurs enfants qui étaient dans des
camps en Syrie je propose à Quentin
calmer de nous rejoindre
rebonsoir Quentin
rappeler comment la France a organisé
plusieurs opérations de rapatriement
depuis l'été 2022 oui la France
organisée trois opérations d'ampleur ces
derniers mois tout d'abord 5 juillet
mauvaise femme et 35 enfants 20 octobre
2022 15 femmes et 40 enfants 24 janvier
dernier 15 femmes et 32 enfants tous
étaient détenus dans des camps de la
zone irakosyrienne beaucoup vivaient
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires à l'image des images que vous
voyez en ce moment le camp de Rogge en
Syrie où sont devenus beaucoup de
familles de combattants de l'État
islamique ces images date de janvier
dernier alors retour en France c'est
toujours la même procédure les mineurs
sont placés auprès des services de
l'aide à l'enfance et ensuite
éventuellement alors grands-parents les
maires ont quant à elle été remises aux
autoroutes aux autorités judiciaires à
préciser le Quai d'Orsay Thomas des
rapatriements qui inquiète la droite au
Parlement oui effectivement la dernière
opération de rapatriement celle de
janvier dernier a donné lieu à une passe
d'armes dans l'hémicycle entre les LR du
Sénat et le garde des sceaux toute la
question pour la droite et de savoir
s'il y a un changement de doctrine de la
part du gouvernement avec ses retours
écoutez un extrait de cet échange le 25
janvier dernier au lendemain de la
troisième série de rapatriement en
France nous apprenons par la presse que
15 femmes et 32 enfants sont revenus
sans compter des 31 femmes et les 67
enfants l'année dernière
assumez-vous ce changement de doctrine
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs nous avons pas
changé la position du gouvernement est
extrêmement claire et elle est précise
ceux qui ont choisi daesh doivent être
jugés au plus près des lieux où ils ont
commis leur crime mais mais ça n'est pas
un petit mais il y a des enfants madame
la sénatrice oui qui n'ont rien choisi
et qui doivent être traités avec
humanité et vigilance
vous injecter dans la population
française des djihadistes alors que
notre pays est déjà gangréné par le
salafisme n'oublions pas n'oublions pas
que la France avec 1400 individus et le
premier pays européen et le deuxième
pays au monde à avoir fourni des
terroristes à l'état islamique alors à
propos de ces rapatriement la droite
suspecte le gouvernement d'avoir plié
face à l'Union européenne depuis que la
Cour de Justice de l'UE a condamné en
partie la France en septembre dernier
dans un avis à la CEDH avait demandé à
Paris de mettre un terme au refus de
rapatriement jugé arbitraire je cite
c'est sans doute cet avis qui a motivé
la France à faire revenir des dizaines
de femmes d'enfants contre une poignée
ces dernières années merci Quentin Roger
vous aviez vous aussi c'était en octobre
après la deuxième opération de
rapatriement voilà poser une question
toute simple pourquoi au ministre de la
Justice est-ce que vous reprenez la
formule de Valérie Boyer vous vous
injectez dans la population française
des djihadistes avec ses rapatriements
ça je n'en sais rien est-ce qu'on
injecte ou pas personne ne peut rien
dire la vérité c'est que moi je me
souviens très bien de ma question il y a
maintenant cinq six mois j'avais
rencontré le garder sceaux j'avais
rencontré les autorités qui m'avaient
tout dit dans les mois précédents
on sait qu'on nous demande de rapatrier
globalement 400 personnes on n'a pas
suffisamment d'éléments sur chacun pour
les rapatrier donc on va faire vraiment
du cas par cas et il y a eu quelques cas
de rapatrier avant l'été 2022 où on nous
disait là c'est vraiment l'enquête
complète a été faite etc et puis en
trois fois effectivement on n'aura pas
trié
150 180 personnes
majoritairement des enfants à 35 enfants
40 enfants 32 ans oui alors les trois
qu'on nous fasse pas le coup de
l'humanité parce que à un moment ça va
être un moyen jamais personne ni à
droite ni à gauche n'a l'enfant de moins
de 10 ans qui n'a rien fait qui est dans
un camp et coupable personne d'ailleurs
quand on rapatrit les enfants on les
confie à l'aide sociale à l'enfance pas
à leur mère sauf que les femmes elles
sont pas exactement des mères de famille
classique c'est pas la mère de famille
qui habite dans une bergerie dans le
Gers ce sont des femmes qui ont quitté
leur domicile en France qui sont allés
dans la zone syrienne où irakienne
qui ont participé d'une manière ou d'une
autre jihad qui ont souvent commis des
actes dont chacun se souvient lorsque
l'état islamique existait et qui ont
déchiré leur passeport enclamer qu'elle
ne voulait plus entendre parler de la
France et que la France était ajoutée
aux orties et qu'on espérait bien
beaucoup d'attentats en France je
rappelle qu'un certain nombre de femmes
et je les dis lors de ma question au
garde des sceaux qui ne m'a pas dit le
contraire que bien des femmes enfermées
dans les camps tenu par les Kurdes après
l'échec de dèche continuer sur les
réseaux sociaux à appeler ojihad et à
dire qu'il fallait continuer la lutte de
daesh alors qu'elles étaient enfermées
alors quand on me dit c'est pas un
problème on peut les rapatrier moi
j'espère que personne a beaucoup de
savoir faire mais je pense que je parle
pas des enfants ce moins de 10 ans
évidemment le problème se pose pas mais
les femmes elles-mêmes ne ou pas des
femmes faciles à réintégrer parce
qu'elles ont commis souvent des actes
très durs Martin Pradel est-ce qu'on
pouvait rapatrier ses enfants sans leur
mère
je voudrais répondre à votre question
mais pardon si je dois aussi rebondir à
ce que vient de dire le sénateur
chaotique je pense que
n'allons
on a une position aujourd'hui qui est
entendue qui est que la le rapatriement
des enfants ne pose aucun problème
pardon mais ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas
il a fallu aller au bout d'un certain
nombre de procédures pas devant des
juridictions judiciaires mais devant le
Comité international des droits de
l'enfant ou la France a soutenu qu'il y
avait une pertinence à maintenir ses
enfants dans ces camps et les premiers
qui ont été rapatriés si je ne m'abuse
c'était en 2018 c'est suite à des prises
de parole de parlementaires mais de
toute tendance du gouvernement pour
soutenir que des orphelins
passaient mais les autres camions
qu'allons-nous faire de ses enfants donc
ça n'a pas été si donc cela dans le
discours public finalement il y a une
sorte de sagesse et disons d'évidence
parce que le danger que peut représenter
un enfant de 3 ans à qui on ne reproche
rien évidemment évidemment et bien
fait que en définitive cet enfant est
fini par revenir maintenant la situation
des mers parce que c'est le sens de
votre question la situation des maires
pour moi elle est en fait terriblement
simple soit ces mers ont commis des
infractions et je pense que disons-le
c'est le cas elles ont certainement
commis des infractions il faut ménager
un tout petit peu on est dans une chaîne
importante la présomption d'innocence
ces personnes méritent disons d'être
jugé pour être pour être un site donc il
faut les juger en France mais je veux
dire qu'il faut qu'elle soit jugée
simplement juger on a on a parlé des
initiatives de les faire juger sur place
mais quel droit quel droit va-t-on
impliquer ce qu'on applique le droit
commencé en Syrie enfin je veux dire
c'est une vraie question est-ce que le
droit syrien permet de juger ces
personnes et puis la Syrie est-elle un
état qui a encore une justice veut-on
véritablement que ce soit des gardiens
de prison sous toutes ces questions qui
ont été posées qui ont abouti au constat
qu'on ne pouvait en définitivement
matériellement pas les juger et moi je
trouve qu'il y a les préjugés là-bas
bien sûr c'est-à-dire qu'à défaut de les
faire revenir en France on n'allait pas
pouvoir les juger alors c'est à dire que
comme ce qu'on est en train de dire la
c'est que il y a une nécessité à ce que
les gens qui sont qui commettent des
infractions soient jugées je pense que
il y aurait une cohérence à dire pour
qu'elle soit jugée autant que on le on
les confie à l'institution qui est
capable de les juger puis ensuite un
problème d'ordre sécuritaire c'est celui
qui consisterait à faire confiance aux
autorités du lieu en l'occurrence la
Syrie pour garder bien ces personnes qui
nous menacent et qui dans l'histoire
dans l'histoire de de ces mouvements
terroristes ont sous une menacé et nous
faire du mal à distance c'est à dire les
maintenir sur le lieu dans lequel à
distance ils nous ont fait du mal cela
nous protégerait soi-disant vous avez
répondu à ma question c'est à dire que
je disais est-ce qu'on peut rapatrier
ces enfants sans leur mère vous dites de
toute façon jugeons ces femmes
possibles sur notre territoire
dépendamment des enfants quand une
personne présente une menace quand une
personne a commis des infractions je
pense que il y a quelque chose de
cohérent à vouloir la ramener à soi pour
la garder et si à la commune des
infractions la juger mais non il y en a
un certain nombre qui n'ont pas commis
d'infraction en tout cas qui ne sont pas
poursuivis et celles-ci c'est un
problème de les garder des tenues et je
pense que dans cette mesure il y a un
problème de principe soit elles sont
coupables et il faut ou responsables de
quelque chose il faut les juger soit
elles n'ont rien fait à ce moment-là il
faut le libérer sur le rapatriement de
ces femmes finalement et du danger
potentiel qu'elle représente la France
avait une certaine pression
effectivement alors pas que venant
d'instance internationale il y a
d'autres pays européens qui avait décidé
de rapatrier et les services de sécurité
de certains pays c'était même prononcé
en faveur du rapatriement c'était le cas
des Belges des Allemands des Néerlandais
des Danois
dangereux de les rapatrier comme les
laisser là-bas
les services sécurité français étaient
pour certains en tout cas assez
réticents et ils expliquaient trois
choses d'abord le nombre des Français et
des françaises étaient plus importants
et toujours plus important puisque tout
le monde n'a pas encore été rapatrié ça
c'est d'abord une question quantitative
ensuite il y a une question si je peux
me permettre qualitative c'est à dire
qu'il y avait des personnes notamment
des femmes très radicalisées qui avaient
été identifiées c'est ce que disait moi
j'ai carotschi précédemment il y avait
un troisième point qui était l'état de
nos prisons avec une surpopulation
carcérale notable la situation a quand
même évolué de ce point de vue là
notamment parce que l'administration
l'administration pénitentiaire a évolué
sur la question de la prise en charge de
la radicalisation je vais vous laisser
détailler vraiment cet argument sur les
prisons mais je vous propose d'entendre
un témoignage là dessus on est vraiment
dans le thème
c'est le témoignage d'un régional de
Fort ouvrière pénitentiaire
Erwan Saoudite alors il réagit deux
jours après l'agression de deux de ses
collègues par un détenus radicalisés
c'était passé à Alençon qu'on est sur ça
la radicalisation c'est effectivement un
des gros problèmes aujourd'hui il y a le
retour des djihadistes aujourd'hui on
est absolument pas préparé à les
accueillir
nos prisons sont pleines à craquer on
arrive déjà pas à s'en sortir avec ce
qu'on a les djihadistes qui vont venir
c'est des c'est des gens qui ont
pratiqué la guerre qui ont qui ont fait
un surveillant pénitentiaire aujourd'hui
il est pas du tout formé à ça enfin nous
on va être complètement démuni et ça
sera nous la chair à canon sur les
coursives pour gérer pour gérer ça enfin
c'est juste scandaleux alors ce
témoignage il y a de 2019 est-ce que ça
a changé depuis
une femme qui se sont échappées y
compris des françaises dans le camp de
hein Issa aujourd'hui très franchement
le l'argument sécuritaire me semble pas
forcément des plus convaincants enfin
vous allez des personnes qui vont vous
dire oui c'est plus sûr de les avoir ici
dans nos prisons d'autres personnes vont
vous dire ben non en fait c'est plus sûr
des avoir au Moyen-Orient parce que
c'est difficile de rentrer et très
franchement entre service même il y a
pas forcément de consensus là-dessus
donc c'est une prise de risque mais
c'est une prise de risque qui est
assumée Roger caoutchi je voyais oui
parce que d'abord mettre pardon mais
quand vous dites certaines n'ont pas
commis d'infraction le seul fait qu'elle
soit elle est en Syrie ou un Irak c'est
une infraction vous n'avez pas vous
rendre sur le territoire
d'une guerre comme celle que pratiquait
daesh donc c'était déjà un crime en soi
enfin je veux dire bon donc bon deuxième
élément beaucoup de magistrats français
nous disent nous vous imaginez bien
quand vraiment on a un dossier solide
sur tel ou telle femme on peut agir mais
dans la plupart des cas les pieds sont
disparus c'est là-bas il y a pas bon
donc on a du mal en réalité à juger
d'ailleurs les jugements qui ont eu lieu
pour les femmes l'un des l'une des
condamnations les plus lourdes a été
prononcé il y a quelques jours
d'ailleurs pour une femme avec 7 ans
mais sept ans sans peine de sûreté sans
rien en général c'est plutôt 3-4 ans
c'est pas non personne n'a été condamné
à 20 ans attendez je termine en revanche
juste pour dire en réalité c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu l'impression des
organisations internationales mais en en
pratique l'un de nos problèmes non
négligeables ce sont les Kurdes
parce que jusque en 2019-2020 les Kurdes
apparaissaient comme des alliés de la
France donc que la
franceication territoriale et nationale
et à partir du moment où la France a
réduit pour ne pas dire supprimer l'aide
au Kurdes les Kurdes ont dit non mais
vous êtes gentil on garde vos types mais
vous vous ne nous aidez plus alors à un
moment ça va pas tenir vous vous direz
agir on n'est pas un travail sur les
peines peut-être les peines qui sont
prononcés concrètement sont plus lourdes
je vous le dis
des personnes condamnées à des peines
qui dépasseraient largement les 7 années
dont vous venez de parler sans période
de sûreté pour des femmes ça c'est
largement vu alors c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que les les juridictions quand il y
a une personnalité qui vient devant elle
avec un suivi avec
une absence de
de tout passage à l'acte violent
c'est quelque chose qui fait réfléchir
et puis il faut comprendre que ces
personnes souvent sont jugées avec un
délai entre le moment où elle se sent
engagées sur ce chemin et le jour où
elles sont jugées on a on a un recul qui
conduit effectivement à ce que on ne
sont pas condamnés au maximum qui est
prévu par la loi
je pense que sur ce sur le sujet de de
des raisons de la difficulté à laquelle
on assiste j'entends ce que dit le
sénateur caoutchi à l'instant sur sur
les Kurdes je pense que les Kurdes ont
été pour nous Français une une solution
ils ont été des alliés opérationnels ils
sont morts sur le terrain pour pour
défendre bien sûr leur territoire mais
aussi pour pour repousser ses forces
terroristes qui sévissaient sur le
terrain et c'est vrai que moi je trouve
que c'est extrêmement curieux de la part
d'un pays comme la France de d'attendre
d'autorité nonétatique qu'elle garde des
prisonniers et que elle rendent la
justice en quelque sorte un peu plus
d'une minute il y a une question qu'on
n'a pas abordé mais j'aurais quand même
vous entendre marquer clair sur le quand
on parle des prisons le risque de
contagion terroristes ou de contagion
djihadistes c'est-à-dire que c'est
détenu qui reviennent ils sont forcément
isolés ils sont comment ils sont pris en
charge l'administration pénitentiaire
est consciente du risque qu'on a eu des
cas de contagions par le passé donc il y
a un système qui a été mis en place avec
une évaluation de ces individus et
ensuite en fonction du résultat de
l'évaluation une orientation soit vers
l'isolement pour les cas les plus durs
soit vers la détention commune avec les
droits communs pour les cas les moins
problématiques et puis entre les deux il
y a une orientation vers des quartiers
de prise en charge de la radicalisation
pour essayer justement de commencer une
prise en charge dès la détention pour
ensuite passer le relais éventuellement
à Perse au moment de la Libération
ça ne veut pas dire que le risque de
contagion est nul il y a des cas et on a
pour le moment parlé que des détenus dit
10 donc des personnes condamnées pour
des fêtes terrorisme il y a une autre
catégorie qui est très problématique en
prison ce sont les radicalisés les dcsr
se dire des droits communs des personnes
qui ne sont pas rentrées en prison pour
des faits de terrorisme mais qui se sont
ou alors qui étaient déjà radicalisés
avant mais qui sont rentrés en prison
pour des fêtes droits communs et ça
c'est une catégorie qui numériquement et
en fait plus importante que les
terroristes et qui dans les programmes
de prise en charge posent davantage
problème parce qu'il y a eu davantage de
cas de réincarcération de ces individus
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat qui était qui était
passionnant je rappelle le titre de
votre livre marketer la guerre de 20 ans
djihadisme est contre terrorisme au 21e
siècle il est publié ce livre aux
éditions Robert Laffont voilà c'est la
fin de ce sens public merci à toutes et
à tous de votre fidélité je vous dis à
demain 18h et 22h et puis votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
dans la matinale Oriane monsini reçoit
Julien Robert le vice-président